[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
leckere orientalische mini croissants
die sind herzhaft gefüllt mit kiri und
passt immer fast immer das ist
getrockneter rinder schinken und
schmeckt unglaublich lecker die
kombination würde ich auf jeden fall mal
ausprobieren
und das sind die zutaten die wir
benötigen das um zwei packungen frischer
blätterteig am besten aus dem kühlregal
außerdem den schiri frischkäse mit sahne
hast du mal das ist der würzige rinder
schinken außerdem noch paprika flocken
meine sind jetzt nicht schafe können
auch die scharfe variante nehmen und
getrockneten basilikum
[Musik]
nun beginne ich damit den rinder
schinken in kleine stücke zu schneiden
[Musik]
sobald wir sie dann fertig geschnitten
haben geben wir sie kurz an die seite
und machen mit dem blätterteig weiter
[Musik]
nachdem wir den blätterteig ausgerollt
haben geben wir zuallererst kelly drauf
und zwar habe ich hier die variante mit
sahne bei kiel gibt es mehrere varianten
ihr habt ja auch zum beispiel joghurt
oder mit kräutern alle varianten finde
ich sehr lecker ich habe mich aber hier
jetzt für die neutrale variante
entschieden damit sie später noch nach
eigenem belieben setzen kann
nachdem ihr dann eine dünne schicht gd
verstrichen habt dem wir zuallererst das
basilikum mit hinzu und anschließend
noch die paprika flocken
[Musik]
nun peilen wir den blätterteig einmal
längst in der mitte durch und
anschließend von oben nach unten in drei
gleich große stücke
[Musik]
somit erhalten wir sechs quadrate die
wir ebenfalls in der mitte senkrecht
durchschneiden so dass wir zwölf stücke
erhalten
zu guter letzt müssen die stückchen noch
diagonal geschnitten werden damit für
croissants auf rollen können wir geben
dann also immer ein bisschen fast immer
auf die lange seite des croissants und
rollen das zuspitzen ecke hinauf so
verfahren wir dann weiter bis wir alle
kosmos aufgerollt haben achtet nur
darauf dass ihr mit der breiten seite
des dreiecks beginnt und dann zur spitze
hin aufrollt
[Musik]
anschließend benötigen wir noch ein
wenig milch zwei kleine gelbe oder ein
großes ein wenig geröstetem sesam und
schwarzkümmel
zum glück gebe ich jetzt noch ein
schluck milch und verhöre das
miteinander
dann kommen die aufgerollten croissants
auf ein mit backpapier ausgelegtes
backblech und werden mit der angeblich
mischung bepinselt damit sie auch eine
schöne farbe erhalten
[Musik]
bei orientalischen gebäck darf
schwarzkümmel sowie sesam natürlich
nicht fehlen also geben wir das auch
noch mal darüber
[Musik]
die mini croissants werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze für 22 minuten gebacken
die fertigen goldgelb gebackenen
croissants genießt ihr am besten noch
lauwarm zu einer tasse schwarzen tee
oder auch gerne einen kaffee und falls
jetzt auch lust habe sie nachzumachen
dann schaut doch mal in die infobox da
habe ich euch alle genauen mengenangaben
aufgeschrieben und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß dabei bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss
[Musik]